I would like to stop the video
and think about how much it does 64 minus 31.
Now let's think about it together.
So what exactly does 64 mean?
We can think of 64 from the point of view of the numbers.
The figure 6 is in the order of the decimal,
and the figure 4 is in the order of the units.
Hence, 6 here means six tenths.
These are 6 groups of 10.
We can illustrate it here.
6 tens, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
groups of 10.
In other words,
6 tens, here are those 60 squares here,
in groups of 10.
And then we have 4 units.
Here are 4 units here.
4 units.
So that's 64.
6 tenths, 4 units.
I have 64 squares in total.
60 blue
and another 4 yellow.
4 units.
Now I want to get 31.
So, what is 31?
31 is 3 decimal and 1 unit.
So let's get 1 unit first.
We will draw this,
we remove it.
We remove 3 tens
and 1 unit.
Let's cross this unit.
How many units do we have?
Now we have 3 units.
We have 4 units minus 1 unit
is 3 units.
Now look at the dozens.
I have six decades.
And I'll get 3 of them.
I scratch 3 out of the titles.
Let me do that.
Let me scratch this one-tenth,
then two decades and finally three decades.
So how much do they stay?
I'm left
only 3 decades.
Only those 3, these 3 here.
We have 6 decades minus 3 tens is 3 tens.
Therefore, 64 minus 31 is 33.
3 tenths and 3 units.
3 tenths, this is a group of 10,
another group of 10 and a third group of 10.
3 tenths and 3 units.
1, 2, 3.